so I don't have enough ducky markers yet
[Music]
so a bit of backstory I just started a
new anime podcast with some of my best
friends in this platform the anime man
and sea dog VA it's cool a trash taste
you can check it out in a year and Lygia
but you know since we just started
there's one glaring problem we've had to
deal with the studio was [ __ ] empty I
mean look at this [ __ ] we're gonna call
ourselves the trash taste anime podcast
and there's zero anime titty on display
someone's gotta fix that [ __ ]
so the solution how about we go to
Akihabara and buy enough anime [ __ ] to
fill the podcast with but let's make it
interesting instead of making it some
standard Akihabara vlog you've seen many
times before let's make it a challenge
and whoever loses would have to do some
kind of punishments so here's the
challenge we'd be given five hundred
dollars to complete as many tasks as we
can and if we go over five hundred
dollars then we go bust and we lose we'd
be heading up for stores in Aki
Harborough with two challenges to
complete and if we complete them we get
a point
don't worry we got permission to film
these stores within just [ __ ] Logan
Paul our way through our key Harbor uh
but in addition to that we'd also have
overall challenges that we could
complete to get extra points like who
bought the most expensive anime figure
who bought two merch from the least
popular anime series so the concept was
all three of us would have our own
different approaches doing our own
things I don't know what they were going
to buy for the studio and they have no
idea what I bought for the studio so
what you're about to see is my
perspective and I basically had one
mission if I can't get monetized
then or canned my [ __ ] friends so
yeah this is the first time I've like
done a video like in live-action right
outside on the streets I'm Joe I'm
joining like the real youtuber gang now
which is right in front of the store
first stop animate now animates one of
the biggest chains of anime stores
globally there's a bunch in Tokyo and
they're even scattered all over Asia I
remember when I lived in Thailand there
was one in Bangkok as well alright how
this is gonna work is that we're gonna
have several challenges all in this
trash can that's we're gonna pick out of
could be anything we don't know what
it's gonna be yet though yeah let's pick
it out and let's see what happens one
one out of time
run all the way to the top floor while
seeing the even doing this seven four
that is their building oh my god holy
[ __ ]
ask the store staff to recommend a
figure and buy it in Japanese
get a figure from a series that you oh
my god sir that's so easy that's so
[ __ ] easy get one female character
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you you've
got is so easy if I get Cox okay this is
this is easy get a deck you figure my
hero academia get a character figure
from the series made an abyss hell yeah
so let's talk strategy there was none
this is the first thing you see when you
enter the store got a represent for the
men of culture here it's like you can
see how much stuff they have here and
this is just like one floor I don't know
if I want this for the podcast but I
want it period dude what is this what
the [ __ ] is this is this is this REM
alcohol who is this is this a sheet ah
it's tough what did you do to yourself
what did you to ished huh I'm probably
gonna get chubby Ishtar I would probably
love this figure if I've seen the show
like what right now I'm just shopping
for myself I've seen more things that I
want to buy for myself then things I
want to buy for podcasts I'm like maybe
I can just spend it on myself and just
be like hey guys
well eventually I had to think about
completing my challenges yeah we're
gonna we're gonna go look for my ear
academia stuff to complete the first
challenge so far I haven't seen many
anime figures but they've got a lot of
other anime merch yeah I don't think I'm
gonna be able to complete the you might
hear academia
okay so I'm gonna try the second
challenge now I'm gonna just gonna ask a
staff member of what he recommends I
think I know what I need to say my
Japanese is probably probably gonna be
very broken I've not checked this so
let's see how this turns out okay think
about this so we're gonna send Don a
collector figure was to me a desk oh I
[Music]
got the assignments he gave me a full
metal alchemist figure because of course
he did
I would probably love this figure if
I've seen the show maybe this is just a
side is it a sign god are you are you
sending me a sign are you trying to tell
me something of course he recommends
ahead with the Herrick one we've
completed the challenges so now I'm just
gonna buy [ __ ] I want we've got three
more stores hit up after this I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna blow it all my
budget for this store okay so that came
out to about $120 next stop a stop so
we're here at the second store which is
called a stop it's all the way up there
on the fourth floor we're in the
building that's called the our keeper
zone now a stop is a secondhand figure
sure you're gonna see how many figures
they have I've wasted so many hours just
walking around the store so I'm a bit
worried because I am NOT going to have
enough time to find every figure that I
want to buy so we're just gonna pick the
challenges now before going into the
store one I want to give a quick shout
out to my camera woman for the day
subscribe to her Sid snap all right I
didn't need this
pass the stuff whether they sell pork in
a fuchsia but please make mine another
really easy challenge you cannot be [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I'm so sold one male
character are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
uncle I can't I can get the most
expensive figure you can find in the
store the most expensive figure you can
find at this store is gonna be beyond
the budget ah I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna do this now buy one item the gig
exceed okay he's hell yeah get a 1 sao
figure and shout i freaking love sao to
the cashier when buying do 10 squats
before you enter the store easy easy
I can do this alright just like that
just just like that baby now
now I can focus on just getting anime
figures how are we going to be on scope
to all this in 45 minutes how the store
works is that you have a piece of paper
and you go around viewing all the boxes
that are available and there are a lot
of [ __ ] boxes you can get lost in
here so easily now we've only got 40
minutes in here so I don't have enough
time right now to go through every box
so I'm just gonna go for first instinct
since i essentially didn't have any
challenges i needed to focus on
completing here i had one goal and one
goal only by as many figures as I can
now because we have a limited budget I'm
just gonna focus on waifu's aqua
darkness or Mega Man I'm gonna go for a
useless chorus just because you said
that I'm gonna go for darkness what is
that oh oh holy [ __ ] also Angel Beats
introduced I'm getting back where's all
the wife isn't they have to I have to I
find I have to
oh just wait oh just you wait that
figure of Marin is actually much cheaper
than the 35 bucks that Miriam figures
even cheaper is it that's a thousand
with we got it
I just got figured in for you and I
forgot I forgot what I was doing Oh
Mikoto where's where's the Santa Clara
box
I need my Center giriboy oh okay Santa
Clara figure did not see that I can't
think I just need to buy I was far
beyond calculating how much every figure
totaled up to nothing let me see your
paper and you don't have it yet ah
rookie name which became a massive
problem when I saw one figure I needed
to get holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I might I
might get it I might get it it looks so
good a hundred and seventy dollars for
one figure was I willing to spend over a
third of the budget on one amazing
degenerate figure there was never a
doubt in my mind I haven't figured out
the budget but I think this biggest
wouldn't not my budget but because of my
earlier strategy I completely [ __ ] up
because I'd forgotten everything that I
had noted down and I quickly lost track
of everything I put down I'm gonna
eyeball two minifigures I brought two
minifigures [ __ ] which one was she
maybe be 59 I'm so confused
where the [ __ ] is be 59 to 23 24 am I
just gone crazy
[ __ ] it I'm sorry I don't remember who
big be 59 was but you're getting
you're getting your show people oh I
might have been targeting [ __ ] if I if I
just crossed out Sagarika I'm gonna be
sighs I'm gonna be so sad [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what what should I cross out what should
I cross out no no no we okay we are
keeping that figure guy's help me budget
this correctly darkness darkness has got
a guy who's the second figure I bought
who's the second figure boy [ __ ] whoever
this is this is [ __ ] oh this this is
like picking between your children it's
so [ __ ] hard all right we're gonna go
we're gonna catch up so what happens as
we give it to the store clerk and then
they bring us over to the boxes which I
hope I've written down correctly for the
rest of them at least and we're just
gonna go collect them yes they always
ask us to check the items condition wow
thanks 4d monetize my video Sydney this
is it boys this is this is where the
budgets going right we're done I came
out spending around $220 which I have
Rome and had spent about three hundred
and forty dollars and I have two stores
left so in the first one our inkay bugs
my goal here is to survive of the budget
I have but first
already being way over budget I have the
challenges to worry about goggle is very
strategic about it gonna feel the weight
of the paper by figure from a shown in
series thank God thank God
get in there stole hope you get a Joe
Joe character figure on do the exact
same totally get something super edgy oh
my god get a contract to soccer fever by
a wolf stroll Wow let's go
good the biggest challenge is going to
be trying not to blow the budget let's
have a look around
this is a lot of figures damn I didn't
realize cabe except this figure now
after dropping $170 on the Ria's figure
and being way over budget already I
thought what else can I do to D monetize
the podcast we're about to enter the
culture zone Oh are these the gin cheese
so these are all docume what can I show
what can I show so these are all dojin
cheese they said this is n hentai in
real life I haven't seen Idol master but
I know that the junkies are top tier
let's check out the faker and order one
two three four five five shelves of fake
ground order not as many as I expected
but still quite a lot why do I only have
a half-hour how can I possibly look at
all this in half an hour I'm gonna have
to focus on just completing the
challenges otherwise I'm gonna get drawn
in we're gonna come back yet you're
gonna try and get the show in and figure
first just to get that out of the way
okay so we're just gonna try and find
the cheapest shown in figure we can
twenty two dollars for a monkey deal
Luffy figure this first one is 117 bucks
also I found this awesome print from
this visual novel so yeah I'm going to
get this for myself so this doesn't
count towards the podcast oK we've only
got 20 minutes left now for something
ludes I was the one who spent the most
time in the K books the other boys had
already completed their challenges and
they were just left waiting for me and
I'm sure they were wondering what I was
spending all my time doing I'm just
trying to find something that I could
show on YouTube okay I think I found a
cover but I can get away with I would
look through more of these but we're
running out of time so I've just got to
settle for John alter I still don't have
her yet though one day this was a
godsend I had managed to complete the
challenges for really cheap there was
literally no reason for me to buy
anything more because that would just
jeopardize the little remaining budget I
have to complete the two challenges I
had to do in the next store so anyway I
bought a dr. Mara ah
ah these are all tacky markers oh oh oh
my god oh my god why did why did I spend
all my budget on figures oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna have to get the cheapest one
who should I go for Hachi I need to look
at price can I get a cure it's a vacuum
are correct I want to get an orange
every $160
am I gonna go bust today so I think I
found a solution this one's this one's
$44 which is the cheapest I could find
so I'm just gonna go for it about $70
$75 I probably journey so I'm very tired
right now and we done last stop was
amiami
it's a pretty massive store I don't have
much budget left to work with so I'm
just gonna be praying and hoping that I
get good challenges to complete we're
ready for the final two challenges
ladies first tomorrow get one furry or
non-human figure do a dance when
entering the store easy by three anime
mugs or glasses get a figure that you
think is trash get one character plushie
you are been so [ __ ] lucky get one
Ava figure okay so the challenges were
right but it wasn't exactly a slam dunk
either army army was way bigger than I
thought it was gonna be it is a [ __ ]
massive store with a lot of great
choices so challenge one let's go for
the AVA figure cuz I know I can get a
neighbor figure oh my god these are some
awesome figures oh alright we're gonna
find the cheapest Ava figure this is
this is gonna be this is gonna be super
hard this is gonna be super hard [ __ ]
what if they don't have an Ava figure
these aren't for sale are they so what
sucks is that there are so many figures
on display and none of these are for
sale oh my god doesn't mean two species
reviews figure
so we've been walking around for a bit
now and I'm getting a bit worried
because I haven't seen many figures on
sale you see any figures but this is our
last bastion this figures over there
some figures over there
I got a pray and hope that I can find
something anything well then I did
manage to find one able figure on
display
we found an Ava figure that's the good
news the bad news it looks like this and
it's $200 this is the only figure I've
found so far I think I'm coming to the
realization that I'm not going to be
able to do either challenges and I'm
probably gonna lose this whole challenge
then Droid androids androids here we go
here we go here we go here we go okay
I'm betting my hopes that moved the
figure I'm looking for somewhere here
bra
give me my ELF get me my ELF okay okay
hope hope hope hope oh my god oh my god
so we've got a few we've got a few
choices here the oscar figure and the
masado and Carrie and Mary figure
they're pretty good but I think we've
got to go for the cheapest option and
we're gonna go for the pop figures now
because I don't think we can budget
these figures well that's the challenge
done now we need to find a furry figure
I don't know what I'm gonna do Pokemon
Pokemon that that counts as very right
I'm having a question there if they had
a Lucario that would be so easy but
right now I don't see a Lucario okay cuz
different Pikachu counts as a flurry
right now what I'm thinking is we get
the Eevee I feel like indeed counts
I mean Phoebe's furry it's nonhumanoid
it works so we're just gonna leave it to
fate now whether I've overspent or I've
kept on budgets and we done boys we are
done let's see how the other guys are
doing how you doing you think you won I
did all my challenges I'm pretty
confident in my purchases my man talking
to you now you guys obviously come in
with like a strap no I think I don't
think when I hit this store I'm just
like I'm throwing a Hail Mary I'm just
gonna hope it hits based on points are
now I have a right I only felt one I
think I talked to
okay so right now it's p76 but that
could all change on the podcast and that
was that but of course there are 10
additional points for the overall
challengers so all of us had to come
together on the podcast to figure out
who had actually won if you want to see
their reaction to everything I bought
along with who the final winner of the
game wars click the link below to check
out the trash taste podcast episode
where we all come together of course I
wanted to fill this channel with some
degeneracy just yuvan know what you just
the question is how much was I willing
to spend on it and also if you want to
check out the other two perspective for
they bought and how their day works you
can also check out their videos too in
the description below this video was the
first for me I don't normally do videos
like this but it was a lot of fun to
collaborate with my mates on a big multi
channel project anyway though that's it
from me we'll be back to our regular
programming next video
- gig up and I will see you all next
time